let's tell you about the Brentford
strike at Ivan Tony who missed out on
England's World Cup squad he's been
charged with breaching fa betting rules
232 times let's get more now should we
from Rob who is in Doha for us this
morning
um hello to you rob we were expecting
him to be in the squad weren't we now I
think we'd probably know why he wasn't
yeah they've been quite a clamor for
Ivan Tony to be included in Gara
Southgate Squad particularly after he
scored twice for Brentford in a victory
over Manchester City last weekend 11
goals for him this season but we
discovered a few weeks ago that he was
under this fa investigation for
breaching betting rules all players are
banned from any form of football whether
directly or indirectly anywhere in the
world and this would indicate now with
the charges coming why and Ivan Taylor
was not selected by Gara Southgate and
the fact he'd only been called At Once
by him in September and never played
well these charges relate to a four-year
period between 2017 and 2021 when he was
at Newcastle Brentford other clubs and
before joining Brent ferdy helped
Brentford gain promotions to the Premier
League for the first time and those
goals really impressing but now he's
facing potentially a ban from the game
one member of actually the England squad
Kieran trippier was banned himself last
year for 10 weeks for breaching betting
rules for telling a friend to perhaps
better on his transfer so these are
serious charges that Ivan Tony is facing
from the fa and they will take some time
to resolve of course the World Cup being
here in Qatar in mid-season very
unusually means the Premier League does
not resume until December the 26th on
boxing day so there is some time for
Brentford do play again and Brentford do
say they are in contact with Tony Tony
himself has only said in recent weeks
where the news first leaked that he's in
a contact assisting the fa with their
investigations meanwhile here in Doha
another day of training today for
England and Wales ahead of their World
Cup openers on Monday England playing
Iran Wales playing the United States in
their first games